[Music]
on this saturday night the verdict is in
the dutch man accused of extorting and
harassing bc teen amanda todd learns his
fate this is precedent setting not only
in canada but across the world
stepping down the chair of hockey canada
resigns over his organization's handling
of sexual assault allegations
plus
abortion ban backlash the republican
party is on the wrong side of history
and i think they're going to pay the
price how the fight over a woman's right
to choose could reshape the u.s
political map
[Music]
global national with bara nasser
reporting tonight jeff semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with breaking news a
bombshell verdict in bc where a jury has
just decided the fate of aiden koban the
dutch national has been found guilty of
harassing and sexually extorting amanda
todd you'll remember the bc teenager
took her own life back in 2012 after
years of online harassment and torment
koban was convicted on all five counts
in what the crown called a persistent
case of online sextortion our remina
deya was in court today and joins us now
with the latest
jeff you could hear the heavy breathing
down the hallway as people raced back
into court for the verdict everyone
stunned a decision was reached in this
complicated two-month-long trial less
than 24 hours after deliberations began
friday the verdict 44 year old dutch
citizen aiden cobin guilty on all counts
in the gallery amanda todd's mother let
out a huge yes as the jury 4 person read
the words guilty five times there are no
words that can explain how my heart
feels
it's
it's just a culmination of of
what amanda endured
and the truths of it all
and
now
aiden covan
has been found guilty which we we knew
and justice has been served
for amanda
this is not what we hoped for or
expected
and now we need to consider our options
so we'll speak to our client
an appeal is a possibility he's
disappointed of course the jury only had
one question pertaining to the accused
conduct and whether it cost 15 year old
amanda todd to fear for her safety and
whether the teen's fear was reasonable
after that it was over within seconds
cobin was found guilty of extortion
possession of child pornography times
two child luring and criminal harassment
coven is currently serving an 11 year
sentence in the netherlands for cyber
bullying dozens of young girls and gay
men he was extradited to canada in
december 2020 to face charges in
amanda's case
a dramatic ending after almost nine
weeks at trial roughly 30 witnesses 80
exhibits the jury's job is now done the
next step is to set a date for
sentencing a hearing is scheduled for
august 11th jeff
all right ramina deya in vancouver
thanks romina
turning now to a high level resignation
in the world of hockey hockey canada's
chairman of the board of directors is
stepping down and his fellow leaders are
now facing calls to follow suit michael
brindemore informed the board last night
and in a statement today says his
resignation is effective immediately and
he has quote listened carefully and
intently to the comments of canadians
about the culture of our sport and our
organization and about our actions and
leadership and immediate action is
essential to address the important
challenges facing our organization and
our sport his resignation follows
mounting scrutiny against hockey
canada's leadership after revelations
the board settled a three and a half
million dollar lawsuit in april alleging
eight hockey players including members
of the world junior team sexually
assaulted a woman back in 2018. hockey
canada says an interim chair will be
appointed in the coming days
tensions are rising in the waters off
taiwan the taiwanese government accusing
china of rehearsing an attack against
the island u.s house speaker nancy
pelosi's visit there this week sparked
angry backlash from chinese officials
launching military drills in and around
the taiwan strait abigail beeman reports
on calls for the canadian government to
respond
a commander of china's people's
liberation army navy declares this
training is about forging a strong iron
fist at sea taiwan says chinese airships
and warships rehearsed an attack on the
island saturday with more than a dozen
chinese aircraft and 14 military ships
crossing the median line in the taiwan
strait it's dangerous because all those
chinese planes you know challenging the
the taiwan borders require that taiwan
sends its jets up to to counter them and
the possibility for a miscalculation or
an error is always there so
you know the whole thing is is
frightening what we've seen china do
over the the last few years
is
move away from
a peaceful
resolution of differences
to doing so coercively
and potentially
forcefully
after the g7 issued a statement asking
china to resolve differences peacefully
canada's charged affairs was one of the
diplomats summoned by beijing in a
statement china's embassy in ottawa
called the g7s position a flagrant act
of hegemony bullying and coercion and
called on canada to stop interfering in
china's internal affairs in any form so
as not to cause further damage to
china-canada relations we're extremely
concerned with what's going on in the
region we call on china to calm down its
rhetoric canada's foreign affairs
minister wouldn't say whether she plans
to summon or speak to the chinese
ambassador i think that canada should be
extremely firm i think it's really
important
for china to understand that its
behavior is irresponsible
china says its air and sea exercises are
focused on six spots around taiwan
expected to continue until midday sunday
abigail beeman global news ottawa
indiana has become the first state to
ban nearly all abortions since the u.s
supreme court overturned roe v wade the
state's republican governor quickly
signed the near total ban on the
procedure shortly after lawmakers there
approved it all abortion clinics in that
state will now lose their licenses under
the new law jennifer johnson reports on
the reaction and repercussions
please vote in the affirmative thank you
indiana state senator sue glick got her
wish as lawmakers passed a near total
ban on abortions the supreme court's
decision overturning roe v wade left the
decision to allow the procedure up to
each state and indiana became the first
banning all abortions accepting cases of
rape incest or to protect the life of
the mother i was hoping for a pro-life
bill this is not a
a truly pro-life bill the bill didn't go
nearly far enough for many conservative
lawmakers you cannot treat rape
one of the worst things that can happen
to someone
you cannot treat that
with abortion but it went way too far
for many others who hope those who voted
for the bill will lose their jobs in the
next election if you're pro-choice you
can't be happy i don't know who left
here happy all i know is people need to
go out and vote in november
under the new law abortions can be
performed only in hospitals or
outpatient centers owned by hospitals
meaning all abortion clinics will lose
their licenses doctors now worry about
criminal charges if they determine a
pregnant woman's life may be in danger
but a prosecutor disagrees we are
frightened there have been a lot of
group chats
there's been discussions about you know
do we stay
anti-abortion activists are applauding
the bill acting swiftly after the
supreme court ended a woman's
constitutional right to abortion in june
now they are promising to take care of
women who are forced to keep an unwanted
pregnancy the state of indiana has the
ability to go forward we can help these
women deliver and deliver safety and to
take care of these babies as they come
along
abortion advocates are vowing not to
give up the fight to repeal this
legislation the new law making indiana
one of the most pro-life states in the
nation takes effect september 15th
jennifer johnson global news washington
the battle over abortion rights is
expected to be front and center in the
upcoming midterm elections in the united
states now historically a new
president's party almost always loses
seats in the midterms but a referendum
in a midwestern state this week has just
upended those predictions and
expectations eric sorenson explains
when the u.s supreme court ended the
constitutional right to an abortion it
only piled more bad news onto democrats
with inflation at historic levels
president biden's approval sagging and
history itself suggesting democrats will
likely lose november's midterms i
thought we were going to do fine
yesterday
shows what i know a president's party
almost always suffers big setbacks in
midterm elections it was a thumping a
thumping for george bush a shellacking
is how barack obama described his
midterm experience feels bad and as
recently as a week ago a survey
suggested republicans will win the house
of representatives handily this november
but history and ordinary expectations
were turned upside down in kansas this
week when the deeply conservative state
voted overwhelmingly to protect access
to abortion sending republicans reeling
i have no explanation and
again it was just a gut punch mckenzie's
referendum suggests abortion rights
could favor democrats all over the
country this november to those of us who
watch politics that abortion is not as
polarizing as really really we think one
poll shows abortion has risen to the top
issue for american women under 50.
people do not want government in charge
of pregnancy in this country the
republican party is on the wrong side of
history and i think they're going to pay
the price this november republicans have
more to worry about than just that we
may just have to do it again we have to
straighten out
former president trump is hinting
strongly he wants to win back the
presidency but the congressional
hearings revealing his involvement in
the january 6th riots have caused his
approval to fall even among some
republicans he's a coward a real man
wouldn't lie to his supporters and
republicans who back trump may be less
electable like john gibbs who beat
incumbent peter meyer a moderate
republican congressman in michigan
ousted by his own party for voting to
impeach trump we're just
sick of the politics sick of everything
being a question of fear or anger one
topic republicans are likely to avoid
now abortion the republicans likely
campaign this fall was going to center
on
the national economy inflation
opposition to president biden but for
democrats abortion will be front and
center in these midterms court
practically dared women in this country
to go to the ballot box and restore the
right to choose to joe biden the supreme
court's abortion decision was a terrible
mistake but also potentially a political
gift to democrats this fall
eric sorensen global news
coming up a bc teen missing for months
turns up dead why the family is
demanding answers from vancouver police
to a global news exclusive now and a
warning this story contains disturbing
details last year a 13 year old from bc
disappeared while in the care of that
province then in may a maintenance crew
made a tragic discovery noel osu was
found dead inside a vancouver housing
unit well global news has learned her
body was inside the room for months and
somehow overlooked by police
sarah mcdonald has the story of the
vulnerable indigenous teenager whose
family says she was failed even in death
for week after week
after week we now know she was here
a 13 year old child who somehow vanished
while in the care of the province noel o
soup's remains only finally found in may
noel had been
in the apartment deceased for quite a
long period of time and in that period
of time officers had come into the
building like they removed
another deceased person while there were
still
two deceased people
in the unit for months global news has
learned the remains of noel and those of
a woman in her 30's would only be
discovered more than two months after
the tenant occupying that unit a man in
his 40's was discovered dead himself his
sudden death is not considered
suspicious but that of noel and the
other female found dead alongside her
are and now under investigation by the
vancouver police department's major
crime section he was found
and then noel a few months later so
there is that gap and of course the
family had questions about that
why didn't somebody do an investigation
right away why didn't they go through
the whole room it's a small room
according to sources the remains of
those two female victims were only
ultimately discovered by building
maintenance staff not vancouver police
following months of complaints by other
residents of an overwhelming and
persistent
foul stench
like oh it smells like that but blood is
has a strong sense i was having a hard
time eating i was just like mortified
grace biliqua who lives in a neighboring
unit repeatedly raised concerns still
the vancouver police department is
refusing to release its call records
involving this building refusing any
comments altogether on its potential
investigative blunder or the identity of
the man who lived alongside dead bodies
for months refusing to confirm even to
family if he's being investigated in
connection to these suspicious deaths or
any others why was she in the unit with
a 40 year old man or over 40 year old
there's no reason for her to be there
the office of the police complaint
commissioner launching an investigation
of its own into the actions of a single
vancouver police officer for neglect of
duty it seems pretty astounding to me
that a single officer is being
investigated for negligence when we have
heard from easily a dozen people who had
interactions with vpd officers and were
ignored and that includes multiple
reported sightings of noelle in and
around this building while she was still
alive it's so upsetting
to think that if maybe one of these
people had been taken seriously
that noel might still be with us an
avoidable tragedy left haunting those
who loved noel and those who never knew
her at all i feel like i could have done
something to prevent that and a child
who fell through the cracks of a broken
system
failed even in death sarah mcdonald
global news
still ahead kenyans prepare to pick
their next president what's at stake for
the country and the continent
you're watching global national
welcome back on tuesday voters in kenya
head to the polls to choose a new
president in the past elections there
have seen deadly violence and
controversial legal challenges well this
time around the cost of living is the
number one issue and as redmond shannon
reports the two main candidates are
former allies and both firmly part of
the political establishment
ballots being trucked across kenya under
armed guard before tuesday's
presidential election we have nothing to
worry about strong assurances in a
country where elections are often
disputed five years ago results were
annulled the vote re-run with only one
candidate incumbent uhuru kenyatta
in 2007 contested results sparked
violence that left 1200 people dead now
the challenger from 15 years ago ryla
odinga is back again running against the
current deputy president william ruto a
former ally turned political adversary
kenyatta can't run again but he's not
staying out of the fray either switching
allegiances after falling out with his
next in command for some voters it all
feels like more of the same
i'm not doing foot
listening
these are the same people we have been
laughing all through these years the
cost of living crisis is hitting kenyans
hard but indications are many doubt that
new leadership will help
the nationally televised debate where
only ruto showed up descended into farce
and only added to disillusionment what
was particularly noticeable was that
young people were not registering in the
numbers
that were expected but one of these men
will win and lead the east african
nation of 55 million forward ruto a
former street trader is campaigning on
promises for small businesses and
cracking down on corruption it cannot be
business as usual
when corruption
is subsumed into government
on that odinga on his fifth attempt at
the presidency is vowing action 2 and
pledging affordable health care
not a single robot should go and cast
those who are sick were in words in the
hospital
go and get them
to take them to the polling station to
vote
online disinformation has stoked ethnic
tensions in the campaign but it's hoped
there will be no repeat of 2007.
constituting
a crime against humanity
not great ruto and kenyatta once faced
charges in the international criminal
court after that violence the cases were
later dropped a peaceful democratic
process now with widespread acceptance
of results would mark a step forward
redmond shannon global news london
up next the canadian charity offering a
helping hand to war-torn ukraine
back a non-profit in victoria bc that
specializes in prosthetics is now
stepping up to help war-torn ukraine
with so many soldiers and civilians
there losing limbs as a result of
russian attacks is kylie stanton reports
the charity is now looking to ordinary
canadians for help
starting from the bottom and working its
way up thousands of tiny layers coming
together over the course of a few hours
so right now we're actually printing the
palm piece while it may not look like it
just yet add the fingers the wrist
socket
and you've got a game changing
prosthetic we've worked in a lot of
functionality into the hand so you know
users can perform a lot of daily tasks
they can use it at home at work at
school for all sorts of things you can
flip the switch the user would actuate
their shoulders close the hand in a
locked position in just a few short
years the hand project has created
roughly 200 prosthetic arms for amputees
in 10 countries around the globe the
majority of which are developing nations
through partnerships with health care
providers and a focus on in-country
production labs have been established
making the prosthetics not only
accessible but also affordable it's
approximately 150 in materials we are a
full-on charity even though we're a
technology developer
we want to basically make our designs
available to help people now they're
hoping to extend that helping hand to
the people of ukraine particularly those
who've suffered limb loss in the war we
want to set up a print center in
eastern europe or in the ukraine and
work with clinicians on the ground there
to make the prosthetic devices the close
proximity means a faster turnaround
allowing amputees to be fit within just
a week or two but the charity is having
trouble finding resources or
collaborators to make it a reality and
is now calling on the public to help
donation or information is key we're
looking for the right clinical partners
the right technology partners to produce
and fit these arms in the region and
that's really the most important things
that we need to get started because i
see this moving laying that groundwork
is what will put the idea within reach
changing lives with a truly hands-on
approach kylie stanton global news
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm jeff semple tonight's
your canada is a bird's eye view of
bancroft ontario we love seeing your
canada so please keep emailing your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you back
here again tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
you